buenos días consiste en mostrar la
unidad de europa y de la otan al mismo
tiempo que advertir al presidente
vladimir putin los peligros que
enfrentaría con sanciones especialmente
económicas sin va de ucrania como ya lo
hemos escuchado el ministro de defensa
ben wallace ha reiterado como lo hizo ya
eeuu que rusia no está cumpliendo lo que
ha prometido de retirar sus fuerzas de
la frontera con ucrania entretanto la
ministra de exteriores lis atrás está
viajando a kiev donde expresará su apoyo
el reino unido a la situación con
ucrania y dirá que todos los ciudadanos
de ese país tienen derecho a vivir en
una nación libre a decidir sobre sus
propios futuros libres de agresión
entretanto se espera que la próxima
semana el gobierno acabe con las
llamadas visas doradas que se otorgan a
multimillonarios que ofrecen inversiones
en este país esto para frenar que
londres siga convirtiéndose en el centro
de operaciones de los socios del
presidente putin anoche
noticiero eyetv reveló citando cifras de
transparencia internacional que
ciudadanos rusos acusados de corrupción
o con lazos con el crimen han comprado
propiedades avaluadas en más de mil
millones de libras esterlinas el 28 por
ciento de estas están ubicadas en el
sector de westminster uno de los más
exclusivos de la ciudad y para darles
una referencia es donde se encuentra el
parlamento británico y el palacio de
para que nada